these are the 13 different indicators
that you have
party mandate before we get to that
member six and you're out
six and you're six and trump is out
right sure so
so let's just go through it together you
can tell me uh who's uh
who's out so party mandate which side do
you choose with that
remember all i need to do is say true or
false okay because it's
it's always based on the incumbent party
so if it's
false that's one key against them
and that one is obviously false because
the republicans took a huge beating in
the midterm elections
which is that that's what it's measured
on so one false
so one false so that that favors just so
the viewers watching is that favors the
dems
right or goes against trump exactly
either way
contest second one uh no primary contest
no
trump wasn't opposed that one is true
okay got it three incumbency
he's the sitting president that one's
true no question third party
ah you know forget about kanye west
didn't even make it to the ballot that
one
is true so the first four which i call
the political keys
only one false only one false which is
the house he lost the house
and he they got a lot of work to win the
house okay yes so
short-term economy well that's based on
whether there's an election year
recession that was looking good
until we got the pandemic recession that
one is false
okay six long-term economy that was also
looking good until we got this
relentlessly negative growth
this year that drove the average down so
far so that's the third
false seven is policy change
absolutely you know he came in intent
on undoing everything obama had done and
he's mostly done it by executive orders
but certainly the policies
now are very different that one's true
social
unrest that was also looking good until
the death of george floyd and the social
unrest raging across the land
so that one is false
so we're now at four falses
scandal number nine ah my favorite key
the scandal key
and we can talk about it but as you know
because i wrote the book
the case for impeachment at the same
time i predicted
donald trump would win i also predicted
he would be impeached
and he was he's only the third american
president
ever to be impeached by the full house
richard nixon resigned
before that happened so that one is
false that's five down
okay got it ten foreign military failure
well you can argue there have been
failures on uh
bush's watch but again these judgments
here have to be objective
and nonpartisan and they have to be
based on how i called the keys since
1860.
and we're talking about big splashy
failures like uh
911 or losing a war nothing of that
magnitude so i count that one as true
so that one is true okay so that that
favors more on trump so foreign military
success
yeah you know i've looked around
he got nowhere in north korea except to
pump up
kim jong-un gave up syria to the
russians
nothing accomplished there nothing
accomplished in iran or in venezuela
now recently we did have this uae
uh treaty with the israelis but it's a
bogus treaty
because it just says suspend annexations
and netanyahu said he can
unsuspend at any time and the whole you
know
god knows how many hours of the
republican convention
you've probably watched it too one line
on the uae treaty one line in trump's
speech that's it so
i don't count that so that one is false
so that one is false in your eyes
we're now six yes so now it's incumbent
charisma
this is the one i get the most flack
about but again
it's not someone's opinion it's how it
fits
my model and this is a very high
threshold key
patrick very high we're talking about
the once in a generation
inspirational candidate like on the
republican side
theodore roosevelt and ronald reagan who
brought in all those reagan democrats
and to win this key you have to be
broadly appealing
trump's a great showman but as we know
he appeals to a
narrow base about 40 to 43 percent and
the strong approval
is 25 to 30 percent more than 60 percent
of the american people
don't trust him and don't like him so
that one i count as false that's seven
so then that's all he needs so and then
last challenger's charisma which is
biden
so if biden was charismatic that would
count against trump but he's not
you know he's an experienced guy decent
guy just as
trump is no ronald reagan uh joe biden
is no jonath kennedy
so that one is true but we have seven
so based on your prediction you predict
who will be president come election day
yes based on my prediction with seven
keys down and only six to count out the
party holding the white house
i predict donald trump will lose and
therefore
joe biden will be the next president of
the united states a reversal
of my prediction for donald trump in
2016.
but remember he was the challenger then
so he
didn't have to defend a record now he's
the incumbent he still doesn't
understand
that he's going to be judged on his
record not on what he says
to be fair with viewers watching this
somebody may say well
he hates trump that's why he would go
against trump you said trump would win
in 2016
when people thought you were crazy for
choosing trump people thought i was
nuts and again i teach in washington d.c
yeah no it's the democrat the democratic
stronghold of the world
and i was extremely unpopular i took
huge heat for it
but i did get a note and it said
professor congrats good call and in big
sharpie letters donald j
trump you want to see it i have it if
you got it let me see it
i got it let me know if it's in the
picture i still
see it there it is